Many of us wake up and have one thing in mind - coffee! Or at least, a drink containing caffeine
To begin his day. But what if I told you that you drank your coffee?
Incorrectly all this period?
All of us have an internal biological clock called the biological rhythm, which organizes many processes
Within our bodies, including our desire to sleep during the day. As this clock
Controls the release of a hormone called cortisol, which often refers to the stress hormone
Because it is excreted at high rates during the body's response to the so-called "theory of"
Cortisol secretion is also associated with your level of alert during the day.
The highest levels of cortisol peak between 8 and 9 am.
This means that your body has a natural mechanism to keep you awake. And while you may think that caffeine
Unable to complete this mechanism, scientists have already found that coffee consumption
Or energy drinks during peak production peak cortisol greatly reduces the effect of caffeine
And increases the strength of caffeine resistance over the long term. Generally, that means you are
I got less cheer, and need larger amounts in the future to stay alert. We analyzed addiction and resistance
Caffeine In one of the past episodes, you can watch them
from here
For this reason, drinking coffee after cortisol flow at 9 am may be better. Scientists
They found a few other times when cortisol was also at its peak: between noon and 1 pm, and 5:30
And 6:30. Which means that the best time to drink your coffee is outside these times.
These cortisol stabilizers - and the bio-rhythm clock in general - are more organized
By means of sunlight, that is, your sleeping schedule does not have much effect.
So what if I woke up too early, or too late? Is it advisable to drink coffee immediately?
Well, scientists have found the fact that cortisol levels are already increasing
Immediately after you wake up about 50% sleep regardless of time. Science says, wait at least
An hour before you start you get a cup of coffee, so your body is well prepared.